here's an overview of the changes we're
going to be making to sunshine will
continue to refer to this map as we move
these coding exercises there are lots of
terms in this map that we haven't
discussed before such as database
contract content provider and DB helper
each one of these blocks represents a
section of our modular data storage
solution we start by defining our data
storage in terms of a contract we then
implement the database using SQLite and
finally we layer a fundamental Android
class between our UI and the data
storage called a content provider
ultimately building our data storage in
this way allows sunshine to leverage
powerful Android frameworks we'll
explain all of this in more detail as we
implement each section let's get started